[Music]
it's december
so we all know what time it is yep we're
approaching christmas at the end of the
year
but my point is that finally cyberpunk
2077 is going to be released it makes
sense that a lot of the delays and
issues with the anime industry spilled
over to the gaming industry and after
delays on top of delays
we're finally getting the much-awaited
game will it live up to the hype
who knows nonetheless this calls for a
celebration so for today
we'll be going through some of the top
cyberpunk shows that anime has to offer
this won't be a top 10 list and i won't
be ranking these titles
instead i'll be throwing some
recommendations your way in case you're
up for a bit of sci-fi and cyberpunk to
coincide with the game
let's get off to a fast start then shall
we let's take to the futuristic
marduk city where our first anime marduk
scramble takes place
madoff scrambles a film series that
tells the story of roon balot the fated
encounter that changes her life comes in
the form of gambler shell septinius in
the dark city where morality is left to
rot
she finds herself being abandoned by
shell to die in an explosion the story
could have ended there but she survives
by being transformed into a cyborg now
she has the means to defend herself in
her second life it's payback time and
roon finds herself fighting for survival
against shells machinations to prevent
her from testifying
against him fast exciting and with just
enough stylish swagger
madoff scrambles a series of films that
will keep you at the edge of your seats
it has some of the best fight scenes
that the previous decade has seen too
and i'll be linking a video where i
feature the movie for you to watch after
this one
[Applause]
we move on from mondoc city to the city
of lux
a man-made underground city that's seen
better days lawlessness rules the city
worn down from neglect
and that's the main premise behind the
next anime technolize
when i first encountered this title i
figured that somewhere roon balant would
have been able to get at least
one sympathizer to her cause this time
that special person is ichisei
an orphan who works as a prize fighter
in the cutthroat city of lux making a
living as a fighter isn't easy
which he experiences first hand as an
incident causes him to lose his limbs
however just like our previous
protagonist ichise would find himself
safe from the jaws of death through the
power of science
this time he finds himself working
heavily with one of the factions
fighting for control over the city
and he encounters ron a girl who has the
power to see the future
together the newly formed duo worked
together in order to prevent the worst
possible
ending a huge faction war that would
crush the city for good
this is early 2000s mad house in action
and as you can see some of their style
has carried over through the decades i
generally like mad house adaptations and
technologies no exception
however i've got to warn you the series
can be rather slow in pace compared to
what the premise will make you believe
nonetheless it's still a good watch and
i find it quite similar to the next
title on the list
while technolise is a very niche title
ergo proxy
certainly isn't so what we've got here
is one of the most beloved and complex
psychological mysteries that the anime
industry has to offer it says a lot when
it stood the test of time and remains
quite popular despite
one not being a mainstream big three
shonen and two not being a
childhood anime fondly remembered by the
people entering the age of 30 now ergo
proxy takes us to the post-apocalyptic
world where the last of humanity have
taken refuge in the city of romdo while
there are no titans to keep people
inside the cities the planet outside is
just as uninhabitable thus humanity has
adapted to life with humanoid robots
called auto revs of course
things go horribly wrong and these
robots contract a virus that gives them
self-awareness
real mayor gets the job of investigating
the phenomenon with her partner iggy as
we can all predict
one answer leads to more questions and
riel must work together with uneasy
allies in order to fully uncover truths
behind the city
ergo proxy has stood the test of time by
mainly being such a pleasant
psychological experience it had its fair
share of action but the main meat of the
series comes in the mystery and how it
keeps the viewers engaged it's full of
intrigue and i feel that i should put
this series as one of my top
recommendations in this genre
the second movie that we're tackling
probably needs no introduction
any anime history enthusiasts would have
likely heard of the name akira by now
largely credited as the anime that
helped the medium breakout in the west
akira is set in a freshly recovered
tokyo after its destruction tokyo went
through a long road to recovery and in
its current state it's a perfect place
to fester unruliness in the form of
terrorism
and gang wars one such victim of this
violence is tetsuo a boy who also
happens to have psychic powers his
powers awaken at the worst possible time
and the unleashed boy begins his rampage
across neo tokyo akira tells the story
of ganida who gets assigned to stop that
friend of his from destroying neo tokyo
for good
being a pioneer of the medium with such
a legacy it's not surprising that akira
gets so much good press however on a
personal note i think that those
accolades are well deserved given the
context it's a very ambitious project
and it has aged well even to the present
day if you're really curious as to why
akira is so good
you need to find it on your favorite
streaming platform and give it a watch
believe it or not there was once a time
when the internet was this dark
scary place full of intrigue and mystery
it represented the depths of cyberspace
and an untapped potential for humanity
and such thoughts can be seen in the
anime
serial experiments lane serial
experiments lane isn't an easy show to
digest even now despite really showing
its age with its interpretation of the
world wide web it still features a lot
of creepy themes that can still hit
close to home today for one the impetus
that starts the story of is a suicide
that apparently came out of nowhere no
one can really tell what prompted chisa
to commit suicide but several days after
her death her friends soon received
hair-raising emails supposedly from the
dead girl herself apparently instead of
just dying
she's abandoned her body to become an
existence within the wired our
protagonist lane finds herself thrust
into the world after opening the email
and she starts encountering surreal
things one after another
strange messages and the men in black
are just the tip of the iceberg in this
mind screw of an anime that tackles the
blurring boundary between reality and
cyberspace now as we've moved on decades
past the millennium
such ideas of the internet seem a bit
foreign after all the internet is where
we meet friends
where we do fun activities make
ourselves famous all of that sort of
stuff to have it looked at with such a
dark lens truly paints lane as a
complete opposite to the sci-fi anime of
today
and just for that different perspective
it's definitely worth looking at
as we approach the end of the list we go
to probably one of the franchises most
synonymous with the word cyberpunk
ghost in the shell
[Music]
a series so synonymous with sci-fi and
cyberpunk and so popular to have spawned
a hollywood movie
count me in but i'm not here to rag
about western live action adaptations of
anime there's another video for that on
my other channel for now
let's take a look at the actual anime
series ghost in the shell
our story now heads to a place where
humanity and machines have practically
become one
humans have long sought for power and
with the help of technology
they finally reached that apex however
such power falling into the wrong hands
can lead to trouble and it's up to
section 9
a special police unit to deal with these
crimes the team
does the job with much success that is
until the emergence of a new hacker
named the laughing man this new opponent
proves to be a formidable foe
throwing the team into disarray and
opening the gates to a cat and mouse
game between him and the team
all over japan how much did people love
ghosts in the shell
enough for it to get a new anime project
it seems mathoko lives on in 2020 and
back in the 90s i didn't expect to hear
myself saying that 20 years down the
line
keep in mind the ghost in the shell has
different timelines but i'd recommend
you go and watch the original 1995 movie
and then go to standalone complex before
you get into other things
i don't think that a lot of cyberpunk
shows deserve having more material that
long into its run
and i guess that it's just a testament
to the mark that this series has left on
the anime world as a whole
however the cyberpunk anime that hits
closest to home especially in modern
days
has got to be psycho pass
i'm not sure i'd call this the top
masterpiece of the urobutcher when fate
zero and madoka both exist but as far as
being socially relevant to the life that
we have none of its works can come close
to psychopaths in a dystopian world
law and order reign supreme or so it
seems then again
what could escape the civil system the
most objective and top-notch way of
determining each citizen's threat level
and their tendency towards crime it also
helps inspectors and enforcers uphold
justice the latter mostly through uh
less glamorous means however what if the
civil system ends up being flawed what
if there's something that technology
can't determine within the heart of a
person
what if the actual bad guys learn to
circumvent the civil system such
mysteries are faced head-on by akane
sunimori and her enforcer partner
shinyakogami a dystopian society where
surveillance is king seemed to be a
far-fetched nightmare when they said but
looking at the world in 2020 it slowly
creates an uncomfortable image of a
possible future
just how much can we put our trust in
authority and these objective standards
in determining our true selves when that
time
comes psychopaths aims to answer these
questions and thus is met with much
controversy on my end though that's also
a big reason why i think it's a must
watch
if you're up for some cyberpunk shows
philosophical elements aside the show is
also extremely pretty with its great
fight scenes
sleek animation and character design and
sound direction
that ends our list of cyberpunk animate
and let's give a round of applause to
these shows that help push the
boundaries of sci-fi in
anime if you were to rank them according
to how you like them how would you do it
i'll be eagerly awaiting your answers
did you enjoy this video it always makes
me happy if you enjoy my videos you can
let me know that you liked the video by
hitting that thumbs up and subscribing
to the channel
with that i'm closing this video and
i'll see you next time
you